(mellow guitar music)
99 Times out of 100,
my reasons are just excuses wearing fancy clothes.
So I gotta decide like, am I gonna live my life
according to my excuses slash reasons, or to my commitment.
(air whooshes softly)
I'mma go back out there.
I got like the sweltering heat.
I got that horrible foot pain.
I got the snake riddled roads of Colorado 10.
They're waiting for me, in fact,
like basically hell's waiting for me.
(mellow guitar music)
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today, returning for his second appearance
on the show, is multi-platinum Grammy nominated
singer songwriter, and now adventure athlete, Mike Posner.
Best known for his infectious pop meditations
on grief loss, celebrity, art and growth,
Mike's songs have accrued billions of streams.
It's a career that includes writing
for and with some of music's biggest stars,
people like Justin Bieber, Pharrell,
Maroon 5, Tom Morello, Snoop Dogg, Nick Jonas and Avicii.
Quite a bit, however, has changed
since Mike and I last sat down.
Over the last two plus years,
Mike literally walked 2000 miles across America.
And he followed it up this past year
by summiting Mount Everest,
racking up a depth of wisdom along the way.
Mike is an old soul.
He is a deep and truly beautiful human
that wears his heart on his sleeve.
He's a guy who's always questing
for deeper meaning and authenticity.
He channels it all into both his art and his life
in a way that I personally find deeply inspiring.
And this conversation, much like our first, is just stellar.
As a bonus, Mike was kind enough to perform a few songs.
So we're gonna open this one up with one such song
and be sure to stick around to the very end
as Mike takes us out with a second live performance
you're not gonna wanna miss.
(air whooshes softly)
♪ Somebody told me God is simply what we don't know ♪
♪ I saw a butterfly, it was dead, but it was gorgeous ♪
♪ And all the robots are just walkin' down the sidewalk ♪
♪ Kings of the little empires that they made up ♪
♪ And I'm wide open ♪
♪ Woo-hoo-ooo ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm wide open ♪
♪ Dusty got shot, and then Osher got married ♪
♪ Stewie's still dead and commitment's still scary ♪
♪ And I got a new woman, but I treat her like my old one ♪
♪ If I keep this shit up, I know I'll end up with no one ♪
♪ And I'm wide open ♪
♪ Woo-hoo-ooo ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm wide open ♪
(air whooshes softly)
It's good to see you, man.
I appreciate you coming in to do this.
Like we said a minute ago,
so much has happened in your life
since the last time we sat down and chatted.
I feel oddly like very connected to you,
even though we don't talk.
Like it was when you came in, I was like,
oh yeah, I just saw him last week, or you know.
I don't know what that is, there's some intangible thing.
But I think you just make people feel very comfortable
and at ease.
Thank you.
I feel, you know, strange
because I feel the exact same way about you.
I feel comfortable around you.
And you're right, even though it's been a few years,
I've felt connected to you.
So maybe we were just like reflecting back-
I don't know, yeah.
The good parts of each,
(Mike laughs wheezily) of each other.
Or Either that, or there's some past life thing going on.
Yeah.
I don't know.
We were brothers.
(Mike whoops softly)
(Rich chuckles lightly)
And the last time we did this show,
I mean, the audience really loved it.
I mean, you're definitely an audience favorite.
So I think people are going to be really happy
to see your face again.
Hey, I'm happy to be here.
Before we get into any of this stuff,
there's so much catching up we have to do.
The first thing that I have to comment on
is I know that you and IN-Q recently went
and spent some time with our mutual friend,
Doug Evans, out in the desert.
That's right.
At his growing
compound out there.
That's right.
And you left that experience
like this new sprouting evangelist,
like you're making videos about sprouting.
I mean, Doug has that effect on people.
Yeah, Yeah, Doug's one, I could call him
one of my best friends, I talk to that guy a lot.
He's an unbelievable
human being.
Almost every day.
And so I was already sprouting a little bit,
but it's really, I spent some time with my family.
I told you I have a house in Michigan
and when I'm there, I spend time
with all the levels of my family
from like the babies to the elders.
And we got a pretty strong
late onset Alzheimer's thing going on.
I've done my 23andMe,
I got both of those genes from both my mom and my dad.
So I really just wanted to start taking that serious,
to do whatever I can and not get that.
So the growing the sprouts at home,
it's been an awesome, it's been fun.
I'm eating like upwards of four ounces of sprouts a day,
which is basically like an entire Mason jar full
and it's great.
I do a staggered system, so I have eight jars.
Like when I first started doing it,
I'd just start all eight at once.
Then I had like eight jars and then.
I did that too and I had so many sprouts.
I couldn't, there's no way I could possibly eat all of them.
Right, so now what I do, I start a new one each day.
So always there's one that's like perfectly ripe.
It's still growing and then it goes.
I mean, there's nothing better, you know.
Like you can buy sprouts from the store
and they're still really good for you,
but they've probably been there a day or two.
These are like alive still
and then they're going in the body.
So yeah, the sprouts is awesome.
And I've really started to dial in.
You know, I always had my macros right.
I was never eating a lot of sugar,
like high carbs or anything like that.
But just dialing in like, where's this stuff coming from,
is there like poisonous toxins in there or not, you know.
And going to the farmer's market more
and just started taking it more serious
because you know, I don't want to get Alzheimer's.
Yeah.
Yeah, I feel you, man.
I got some of that in my family as well.
But you spend time with Doug
and it's not gonna be long
before you're like 100% fully raw vegan.
That's right, that's right.
You know?
Yeah.
He has such an infectious energy
and you just wanna follow his lead
because he has so much enthusiasm
for these lifestyle habits.
He's so passionate about it
and you can't help, but like, you know,
sort of absorb all of that energy.
I agree, he's a beautiful man.
Have you sat in the tubs
that he's got out there
and everything?
Oh yeah.
Well, he's got all these great hot springs there.
But you know, I got the opportunity
to spend some time with Wim Hof,
I said, Doug, you gotta get some ice baths out here, man.
So we're working on that.
He doesn't have the ice baths going on yet?
Not yet, he will, he will.
Yeah, he will, I'm sure he will.
I know you spent time with Wim,
we're gonna talk about that.
First of all, man, you look great.
You look healthy.
Thank you, it's the sprouts, man!
It's the sprouts.
Yeah, that's what it is.
(both laughing lightly)
And then you share these recipes on TikTok and Instagram.
Yeah, I do this, so the Posner sprout recipe,
take some broccoli sprouts,
drizzle it with hemp seed oil,
pink Himalayan sea salt and nutritional yeast.
And that's it, you just-
Dole it down.
Just eat it straight.
It's great, man.
And I'm, you're right, Doug has infected me.
So like anytime artists come over to work in the studio,
I'm always giving them sprouts.
And they're like hesitantly putting it in their mouth
and they're like this is awesome,
I could eat this all day.
And I'm like buying them a sprout kit, it's great.
This is the real bud.
Yeah, yeah.
It's so funny.
Yeah.
You're back in LA, welcome back to town.
Thank you.
I know you've been collaborating
and back in the studio and making music.
But when we last talked, it was right on the precipice
of you beginning your walk across America.
So let's like traverse that experience first.
Great.
Yeah, after we spoke, I was getting ready to go
and I actually got injured before I even started.
I walked into a-
I remember.
I can't remember if this is right after we spoke
or right before, but you know I had the date set,
March 1st, 2019.
I was gonna start Asbury Park, New Jersey.
I posted it on Instagram.
People were gonna come, it's gonna be as beautiful thing.
And I was outside at this like pool party.
Everyone is like drinking and stuff.
I'm not, I'm focused 'cause I'm getting ready
to walk across America in a month.
And I go inside to get a water
and I walk into the leg of a table
and I break my pinky toe
and I had a stress reaction on my second metatarsal.
So it was like, I went to the doctor and he's like, man,
if you want any shot of completing this,
like you gotta let this heal.
And it's like, okay, so before I even go,
before I even take my first step is a reason for me to quit.
Right, obstacle number one.
Yeah and it's just like, okay,
there's gonna be a lot, many more of these.
And I let the thing heal.
And I show up off the coast of New Jersey,
Asbury Park and I got two feet in the ocean.
The saltwater waves are crashing over me.
And to be honest, I'm scared because I told everybody
that I'm gonna walk across America
and the is 2,800 miles, we think,
the route that we've picked.
And I just have no idea if I can actually do it.
I have a belief inside me, you know,
but I don't really know for sure.
There's no way to like really know,
there's no way to fully prepare.
You can't do like half or you know what I mean?
That's true of tackling anything hard.
Of course.
You wanna know exactly how it's going to play out.
You wanna know what steps you're gonna have to take.
You wanna be able to foresee every obstacle
and how you're gonna meet it.
And it just doesn't work that way.
No.
So with all this anxiety and uncertainty,
I stand in the ocean and I take my first step.
And step one is take one step, right.
Step one is take one step.
And I keep walking.
I walk across the lush fields of New Jersey.
I walk across coal country in Pennsylvania
where I share the road with Amish buggies.
I see a double rainbow in Ohio.
I started to develop like horrible plantar fasciitis,
which I'm sure you're no stranger to,
And like I wake up in the morning
and I can like barely stand up.
But I keep going anyways.
I walk across Indiana, Illinois.
I walk into Missouri during a heat wave
where, you know, like the weatherman is on TV
saying, stay inside.
I'm like, screw it, I'm gonna walk 24.
I'm walking usually 24 miles a day.
I walk into Kansas, I walk across Kansas
where I just saw unbelievable shooting stars
and like orange sherbet sunrises every morning behind me
that are so beautiful
that I'm turning around to walk backwards.
I'm walking to Colorado.
And I've walked 1,797 miles at this point when, ahhh.
I think what the, like pain shoots up my leg,
and I'm like, what the heck was that.
And then I hear a sound I don't wanna hear.
(Mike mimics rattlesnake rattling)
Then I realized that a poisonous rattlesnake
just sunk its fangs into my left ankle.
And at first I'm not thinking too much of it.
I'm trying to just stay calm.
But I glance around and there were two fans there
that showed up to walk with me, but no gas station,
no barns, no houses, not even any cows.
Like this is bad.
They call 911 and while they call 911,
it was sort of like the end of Looney Tunes,
if you remember that.
Where it goes like this,
the circles converge on the center of the screen
and it says, that's all folks.
Well, that's exactly what started to happening to me,
except instead of colorful circles, it was darkness.
And just, you know, blacks creeping in
from the corners of my awareness
and I could feel myself fading away.
Now they let me speak to 911 and dispatch says,
sir, I've sent an ambulance from two different towns
and a helicopter, whatever gets there first, get in.
And I asked, am I gonna die.
And the voice on the other line says, I don't know, sir.
I'm sitting there, I'm like this is not bee sting, you know.
And an hour later, I'm in the back of an ambulance.
It just dawns on me, like this could be the end of my life.
This could be, hopefully not, you know.
If they get me there, it all works out, but could not.
And I just, I made a decision, Rich,
that if indeed it is gonna be the end of my life,
I'm not gonna waste it worrying
about if it's the end of my life.
Like, so I literally have this moment
in the back of the ambulance where I'm just reclining.
It almost felt like I was in some enlightened state.
And right when I made that decision,
I started to see, like the colors became more vibrant.
And like I noticed this red paint
on the back of the ambulance door,
and it was like really red.
It was beautiful and vibrant and alive.
And there was just peace and everything made sense.
Long story short, I go to the ICU for three days.
I thought, you know,
they have this medicine called antivenin.
Right.
And I thought-
Just get the shot.
Get back on the road.
I thought if I get that,
'cause it's called antivenin,
I thought I'd be walking the next day.
It doesn't work like that.
The antivenin just like makes it so you don't die, you know.
But the doctor, you know, you're gonna be here while.
Gotta watch your leg.
And my leg swelled to like basically
the size of an elephant trunk.
Yeah, you shared photos of that on Instagram.
Yeah, yeah.
It was very haunting.
Yeah, yeah, it got real big and real painful.
And I went from walking 24 miles every day
to like I couldn't walk to the bathroom without help.
I had a walker and like somebody holding me.
Relearning how to walk.
I mean, were you in the hospital for five days or so?
I was the hospital five days, ICU for three.
And then, you know, due to amazing medical care
at Park View Hospital in Colorado,
I started to get better.
And then actually came the hardest part of the snake bite.
It wasn't actually getting bit by the snake.
The hardest part of the snake bite
was getting better from the snake bite
because I went, after the hospital I wasn't ready to go.
I basically had to rehab, took three weeks.
Right, you went back to Michigan, right?
That's right.
Kinda heal up.
And while I was there, everyone is like coddling me,
cooking for me, wishing me well, you know.
They're putting me on the news.
John Mayer's DMing me on Instagram saying speedy recovery.
I'm in like this nest of cuddly sympathetic softness.
Right.
And-
The idea of putting yourself back
into that difficult situation becomes all the harder.
It's horrible.
After the break.
And yeah, three weeks and I just can't deny it any longer.
My ankle was healed.
And so, I'm looking at the map and I have 1000,
you know, that's 38 marathons.
I have 1000 hot, horrible miles left.
And I gotta decide like,
just like when I walked into the table and got hurt before,
like I have another reason.
This is a great reason actually,
because if I quit, no one will even think I'm a quitter.
They're like, hey, I almost died.
It wasn't meant to be, whatever.
But I started to realize like 99 times out of 100,
my reasons are just excuses wearing fancy clothes.
That's it, they're the same.
Reason, excuse, it's the same thing.
So I gotta decide like, am I gonna live my life
according to my excuses slash reasons or to my commitment.
And I said, screw it, man, I'mma go back out there.
I got like the sweltering heat.
I got that horrible foot pain.
I got the snake riddled roads of Colorado 10.
They're waiting for me, in fact,
like basically hell's waiting for me.
And it's like, screw it.
You know, I wanna meet to hell too, let's go.
So I go back to the exact spot.
And I was like scared, man.
I was having like nightmares about snakes.
I still don't like snakes, you know.
I didn't wanna go back to that spot, you know.
Yeah, of course.
It was scary.
The PTSD of it.
What's interesting is,
to kind of create a little bit more context for this,
the whole idea behind the walk.
I mean, I know there's this kind of origin story.
You were in a Teeny's jewelry shop
and somebody had mentioned that they had a friend who did it
and that kind of planted the seed.
But the seed is germinated over the course
of you completing this album
and being faced with the prospect
of having to do the traditional kind of promotion behind it
and realizing like, you couldn't get up for it.
Like I just can't do that.
Yeah.
And the obstacles there being,
like all of these people who are so heavily invested
in the success of this music,
it took a lot of gumption and courage
to opt out of that and say, I'm not gonna do that.
I'm gonna do this other thing.
And I'm sure there were a lot of people
who weren't very happy about that at the time.
Yeah, I'm not sure if we covered it last time.
You could, I don't know if you remember either,
it was a while ago but-
I didn't go back and listen to it.
We probably did talk about it but.
But yeah, I was, I had the dream of doing it
like five years.
And you're right.
I felt like I was just caught under the weight
of my own life.
And I had done all the research
about the walk across America.
It turns out there's a strategy to it.
Best to start east to west
'cause of where the mountain ranges line up.
And best to start in spring, early spring
in an effort to be done before winter.
So each time spring rolled around
it was something in the way.
Right.
It's an album I gotta finish.
There's a tour I gotta do to support the last album.
Its never gonna be convenient.
There's a wedding I got to go to.
And I just didn't do it,
five years I was letting my dream die
and I felt it, man.
It's like I started to have this low-level depression
kind of creep into my life.
And I was talking to another guy,
I think we have in common, Elliot Bisnow.
Sure, Elliot and I went to the same high school.
Is that right?
Yeah.
How about that?
So I was talking to Elliot-
Julie talks to Elliot all the time.
Amazing, yeah, he's another guy
who just exudes superhuman enthusiasm.
So I said, let me talk to him
'cause I feel utterly uninspired
and maybe his positivity will like,
through our conversation, seep into me, you know.
And so, I told him, yeah, I was like,
dude, I just can't do this anymore.
This whole like Mike Posner show going on the road.
You know, doing the shows, yeah, put your hands up.
I can't do it.
He goes, well, what do you wanna do.
I said, what I really wanna do is walk across America,
but I told my manager, they all think is crazy.
He goes, that's great news!
And I'm like, what do you mean.
That they think it's crazy, it's great news.
So I'm confused.
I'm like, what are you talking about.
He goes, you gotta understand,
not all crazy ideas are great,
but all great ideas are crazy.
And I think you walking across America is a great idea.
And that was it.
He told me that.
And you gotta live
your life, man.
I felt it.
I felt it like the-
Dream deferred.
I could feel the truth underneath what he was saying,
and it was just like,
there's never gonna be a right time.
No one's gonna roll out a red carpet for me.
People are always gonna have a reason
why I shouldn't do this.
You're gonna hurt your body.
You're gonna, like your career's gonna suffer.
I'd heard them all, but it was like, this is my life.
And I'm either gonna live it,
like this is either gonna be a part of my life,
this walk, this dream, or I'm gonna live
some other like crappy version
that I know isn't my truth.
Right.
But there's also this idea of what the walk
was gonna be like versus the reality of it.
And on some level, you could frame it as a unique
and different way to promote your music.
Like I think there was this sense like,
the music's coming out and I'm gonna go from town to town.
I'm going to play these shows
and walk with a bunch of people.
And it'll actually be like kind of a grassroots way
of sharing my music in a different format essentially.
That it would be like this moving carnival across America.
And it started out like that.
It looked like, and I remember you sharing on Instagram,
you would be in these college towns or whatever.
And there'd be a bunch of young people
and you kind of end the day with a little mini concert,
but then slowly but surely the people start to fall away.
And the reality sets in of just how difficult
this is gonna be.
(air whooshes softly)
(mellow drum music)
(birds chirping softly)
(air whooshes softly)
I thought it would be a little bit more
of like a hippy dippy experience.
I'll meet some beautiful people like,
hey, you seem nice, maybe I'll spend a few days here.
But then I started looking at the map and the miles.
And it's like, you got these fricking-
Doing this for the next two and a half years.
You got these fricking Rocky Mountains,
and they're 2000 miles away.
And look, I don't wanna be there in November.
I wanna be there in August, you know,
or September at the latest.
And so the math just didn't work
with that hippie divvy thing, you know.
It became this exercise in extreme discipline
because it's freaking hot, you know,
walking through the summer in Missouri and Kansas.
So it's like, you can't roll out a bed at 10:00 AM
and start trying to get 24 miles in, you're gonna cook.
So I had to get up that, I didn't have to do anything.
I chose to get up at four every day and start,
try to be walking by five.
And I could get pretty much 20 of my 24 miles in,
before it started getting really hot.
Anyways, I say this to illustrate that
I never wanted to do it.
Every day my alarm went off and I never wanted to get up.
It's 4:00 AM (chuckles) I wanted to sleep more and-
Musicians don't wake up early anyway.
Right and so-
You're probably not a morning guy constitutionally.
I'd like to be, you know,
like my job makes it hard sometimes.
Like sometimes we start work at 10:00 PM,
so you don't wanna be super tired anyway.
But on his walk, yeah, I never wanted to do it.
And I just had to decide every day I'mma do this anyways.
And
it didn't matter,
also, it didn't matter how I felt emotionally.
Like the thing went off 4:00 AM and some days I felt sad,
great, get up and walk.
Right, it doesn't matter.
And next day you feel happy.
It's like, great, get up and walk.
And I started to realize like,
I don't know anybody that's happy all the time
or always in the zone, I'm certainly not.
But I know people that show up all the time, you know,
like they're there for their commitment.
Their word means something.
I wanna be one of those people.
And I do remember us talking about that last time.
Yeah, this idea that integrity is super important.
And that shows up on the Everest challenge as well.
Like I said, I was gonna do this thing,
like, I'm gonna do the thing.
Yeah.
On Everest, that was the only thing left.
And we can talk about that later.
But yeah, man, I went back
to the fricking spot snake bit me, and I walked.
Where it bit me, I could just see the Rockies
on the horizon, like real small.
And it was really cool to see the Rocky Mountains
having walked from the Atlantic ocean.
So I just, you know, I went back to spot,
took a step, kept taking steps.
Went up and over the Rocky mountains.
And then like, I felt like I had an invincibility cloak.
It's like this snake bit me.
I went over to the mountains, I could do anything.
I started to dream while I walked.
I started to have this vision of myself
climbing Everest after the walk was over,
but I still had a long way to go.
So I had to stay focused.
I walked across Colorado, walked across the Navajo Nation,
walked across Nevada, walked into California, you know,
walked through the Mojave Desert, walked into LA.
I could see the Hollywood sign on my right, kept walking.
You know, the pavement turned into sand
at Venice beach, kept walking.
My walk escalated to a sprint
and six months, three days after I started,
after walking 2,851 miles, I dove in the Pacific ocean.
And I thought I'd feel accomplished.
But interestingly, I didn't feel accomplishment
in the water, I felt possibility.
It felt like the first day of my life.
I think that's a really crucial insight.
This idea that there are no finish lines.
That it's just another step on your path.
Yes.
This notch in your belt,
but really just to checkpoint, right.
This idea of checkpoints rather than kind of end points.
And when you can kind of contextualize
your accomplishments in that way,
I think that keeps the ego at bay a little bit.
It allows you to have a little bit more gratitude
and humility and keeps you on track for what's next.
Yeah.
I think it's fine to celebrate these things
and acknowledge like I did this hard thing.
Of course, right?
Yeah.
But you gotta keep moving.
That's right and I shouldn't have,
because my body is pretty jacked up.
Like I'm sure you've been there probably worse than me,
but just from doing that same repetitive motion
for six months-
I'm sure.
It just hurt, man.
Like if I sat down, I stood up,
like, it really hurt, everything just hurt bad.
Like, yeah, I was a little worried
that it would feel like that forever.
Like maybe I'd jacked myself up.
But I was so like, I was so hypersensitive
of over celebrating it that I had this boxing coach,
coach Marcelo in LA, and I said,
can you meet me at 4:30 tomorrow.
He said, yeah, no problem.
So the day after I finished the walk,
I go boxing with him.
Right.
'Cause I just needed, like I needed to-
Switch gears.
Part reset.
I needed my body
and my spirit and my mind to know,
look, we're not done.
Like this thing is over, this chapter,
but beginnings hide themselves in ends, you know.
Like we're working tomorrow too, you know.
So I just had to get up early
and work hard again the next day.
Yeah.
And during the walk I had somehow,
Elliot connected me Colin O'Brady.
You know Colin, I think.
Sure, very well.
And Colin, I started ask him about Everest
'cause he had summited it before.
Well, before we even-
Okay.
Get into that, like-
Sorry, jumped the gun.
Well, there's a couple
of things, yeah, yeah.
No, it's cool, we got time, bro, we can breathe.
Before we completely move off the walk.
I know that there was this idea.
Well, first of all, when you were in the hospital,
I just remember you sharing videos of that experience
and being with the walker and being really transparent
about what you were going through at the time.
And I don't remember the details of that.
Other than like seeing this person
who was incredibly positive.
Like you were smiling and you were like, happy,
like that's the moment where you're like,
shit, man, this whole thing went out the window.
I didn't want this to happen, it's a disaster.
But you had this big smile, like you do right now,
and you're like, I'm in here
and they're treating me so well and like-
They were, yeah.
Where does that facility to hold on
to that kind of unbridled level of optimism come from?
Goggins, one word, Goggins.
And I don't remember what,
I don't remember if it was in his book
or on your podcast or another podcast,
but I heard him talking about visualization.
And I believe in like the law of attraction, all that stuff.
Like before I went on this walk,
I was writing in my notebook,
I, Mike Posner, will walk across America,
like a hundred million times.
And going on walks just saying that
like it's my mantra in my head.
And so I really believe it.
Okay, we know about that kind of visualization.
You visualize yourself being successful.
But somewhere maybe it was in his book, I heard Goggins say,
you gotta visualize when things go wrong too.
And so before I left, I did that.
And I visualized myself breaking a leg
on the walk somewhere.
And I just visual, I saw myself like rehabbing it,
going back to the same spot where it broke and finishing.
So I just, I had already-
You already rehearsed that whole thing,
like, okay, here we go.
I already knew that, yeah.
This is what happens.
It was already, the decision was made.
And so, I never had to battle that internally
at that time of the injury,
because I had already done it in my head.
So I got, our boy, David, thanks for that.
He has a tendency to have that impact on people.
And it's like I had, some law of attraction person
might say, well, maybe you attracted the injury.
Maybe I did, you know.
But I had done enough research on this thing
and talked to enough people that had done the walk
to know like, hey, man, you're not gonna go
almost 3000 miles without something bad happening.
That's actually why you're going
in the first place.
Right, 100%
You wanna go feel that horrible moment
and see if you're gonna decide to keep going, right.
That's why you're doing it.
Those are the teachable moments.
That's right.
Those are the experiences that give it
the value that you're seeking.
That and there's a second part to that optimism,
which is way less valiant or noble.
It's like, hey, man, when we're out there,
it's just like, it's just hot and hard.
And when I was hurt, even though my left leg
was like in a lot of pain, the rest of me
actually felt really good taking a break.
And like I was in air conditioning,
I was sleeping in a nice bed.
So it was easy to smile about
that kinda stuff.
And nobody could harsh
on you for that, right.
Yeah, so that was part
of it too.
Like, how convenient.
The hospital was a lot nicer than the walk.
What were some of the more impactful experiences
that you had, besides the rattlesnake bite along the way?
I mean, I know from people,
I know a bunch of people who've run across America
and walked it, et cetera.
And one of the recurring themes that always comes up
is how profound it is to traverse the Navajo Nation.
Yeah.
(Mike exhales audibly)
That was a place that I was warned about
before I got there by white people.
And they say, be careful when you go there,
bad stuff happens, that kinda thing.
And when I got there,
there was just this outpouring of love
and support from the Dene people.
Dene is what they call themselves,
Navajo is like a white word that got thrown on them.
And yeah, man, so basically on the walk,
most of the time you're walking on the side of a busy road.
And people were just stopping all day
and they'd come out on the shoulder of the road
and they'd say, can I pray for you.
I say, yeah, of course.
And they would pray for me in their language.
And they'd give me gifts like arrowheads
and someone even gave me an eagle feather,
which is like this very high honor
that I definitely did not deserve.
But like, let's be real about it,
I'm a white guy walking on their land.
They should be skeptical of me.
They have all the reasons, talk about reasons.
They have reasons to be skeptical of me.
Maybe reasons to be hostile to me.
But they weren't, they were just loving
and that sort of love for no reason touched me deeply.
And yeah, just that 180 miles was,
even if that was the whole trip,
that would have been life changing.
Yeah, that's amazing.
Now another story.
So after I got off the Navajo Nation,
I was walking on the Hualapai Reservation in Arizona
and this big red F-350 pulls to the side of the road.
I'm sorta like hesitant, I guess, I don't know,
I have some judgment or bias about the person
who would drive that kind of big truck.
I'm like a little scared of them,
even though I haven't even seen them yet.
And this young man gets out of the truck
and he's on the other side of the highway,
'cause I walk into traffic always.
I wanna see the people.
And so he runs across the highway dangerously
and it's a 21 year old named Rowan.
And we sort of have small talk for awhile.
And before I left, this friend of mine
taught me a question that you can ask,
that basically, if you get caught in small talk,
it's like a cheat code to go deeper.
And the question is, if I pray for you,
what should I pray for.
And so I asked this.
That's a good one.
Yeah, I asked this young man,
if I pray for you, what should I pray for.
And his name is Rowan, he's 21.
And he thought about it and he looked at me
and he said, five years ago, my dad died from drinking.
And three years ago, my only sibling,
my big brother died from drinking.
And just three months ago, my mom died from drinking.
And he said, if you pray for me, pray for my sobriety
'cause I'm the only one left.
And then, he turned and he ran
back across the highway dangerously.
He reached into his red F-350,
pulled out this small leather satchel.
And he runs back across and he puts in my hand.
He looks me in the eye, he says,
this sweet grass and sage.
He goes this will keep you safe
while you walk on our land from bad spirits.
And he got back in his truck and he drove away
with a hand out the window like that.
And you just, like moments like that,
they're everything, you know.
That's beautiful,
I mean, I think-
How can, yeah, go ahead.
Sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt you,
but I couldn't help but reflect
on the extent to which like death
is this theme that looms large
over so many of these pivots
and decisions that you've made.
I mean, in many respects you can track
the decision to doing this walk
back to the grief and the self-reflection that came
with losing your dad and Avicii and Mack Miller,
and all these people that you've been close with
in your life who have passed away.
Leaving you to ask these deeper questions
about yourself and your purpose
and what it's all about and all of that.
And so it's almost like perfectly orchestrated
for Rowan to cross your path
and share his version of that experience.
And when I hear that, it just affirms to me like,
oh, this was meant to be, you're on the right path.
Like, this is what this is about.
Yeah and I just can't get over his spirit.
Meaning, like, what do I mean by that?
Like how, when he was telling me that story,
he wasn't looking for sympathy.
Like he was there to support me.
That's why he showed up to give me that, you know.
It's like how can someone who has been through so much
have so much left to give still.
And that was just beyond beautiful to me, you know.
And I won't forget it.
Yeah, I think you came across somebody who was doing
an unsupported transcontinental run
also, right?
Yeah.
Like my friend Ricky Gates did that.
He's got crazy stories about,
I mean, that's a whole other level,
but that's also like a shot in the arm of like,
hey, man, when you think it's hard-
Totally.
Look at what this
guy's doing, he's sleeping on the ground.
It's so cool, because when you make a decision,
and I'm sure you've experienced this your life too.
You make a decision you're gonna do this thing.
And like, for me, for our examples sake,
the walk across America, we could use that.
Everyone in my normal life thinks
that's like a pretty wild thing to do.
But all of a sudden, by making the decision,
I'm thrust into this new community of walkers and runners.
And in this community, I'm not special at all.
In fact, I'm probably-
It's completely normalized.
It's normalized and actually, in that community,
I was probably in touch with eight people or so
that were either walking or running while I was,
and I was the least impressive one of the bunch by far.
I was walking supported,
meaning I had a friend going ahead of me in an RV
that was getting food, finding places for us to sleep.
And also I didn't have to carry everything
'cause we had this support vehicle.
So I just got like a little Camelback on, you know.
And you're right, there was this other guy,
like this actually the day before this snake bite.
It was in Colorado.
And we're in La Junta and yeah,
somehow on Instagram we had noticed each other.
And we figured out, hey, this is guy named Stevie,
he's going west to east, he's running unsupported.
And I'm walking east to west, we're gonna fricking cross.
So we say, hey, we gotta link up, right.
So we're texting and we cross in La Junta.
And look, Rich, like he seemed like a really nice guy,
but this day is like tough, so I ain't going east, okay.
I go west, man, that's it.
Right?
Like, or maybe like-
You meet and it's like, if we're gonna hang out,
which direction are we going in?
Like if you wanna talk here for a while,
but I'm not, like I'm go east, bro.
This guy, like, we didn't talk about it either,
but he just turned around
and he walked 16 miles with me backwards
to be with me to connect.
He had a giant backpack on
and he was running 40 miles per day.
He had a ukulele bungee corded
to like the outside of it.
He didn't even use a tent,
he would just sleep on the ground.
He'd wake up sometimes like police kicking him in the head.
And like he, just everything I did, it was times 100.
And then I remember, he asked me,
he goes, what do you do for a music and headphones.
I said, somewhat proudly,
I said the first eight miles I walk every day
is a silent meditation walk, you know.
I was like really doing it.
And then I go, and then after that, you know,
so I put the headphones, I call his stuff.
Talk while I walk.
Right, you make rolling calls.
Yeah.
He goes, I didn't bring headphones.
Right.
What, he goes, I didn't bring,
he goes, I just want to be deeper with myself.
He goes, sometimes I look on the phone for directions.
But other than that, it's just me alone in here.
He goes, it was horrible at first,
but after a month, it's the best thing I ever did.
I found a clarity that I didn't even know
was possible inside me.
And yeah, stuff like that.
Just inspiring, you know, inspiring.
And the next day I got bit by the snake.
I got better and when I went back,
I said, look like, I'm still gonna walk supported,
but no headphones the rest of the trip, you know.
Like I'm going to do it how Stevie does it, you know,
just here, that's it.
No calls or if I'm walking, I'm just walking.
And you did that.
Yeah, 1000 more miles.
And it was, he was right, you know.
It was like the clarity you got,
just, it was unlike anything I knew
before.
And what,
like how would you characterize or articulate,
like what that experience taught you,
like that latter half of the walk
where you really went deep and inward
in a way that you hadn't before?
Just having the time to stop.
Like, let's say somebody, a friend or something
did something that bothered me or whatever.
Usually I'm moving so quick.
I might not even think about,
I'm like, oh, I'm just off to the next thing.
But then you'd have eight hours to think about it.
And so everything was just, all my relationships cleaned up.
You know, if there was something
that bothered me with someone,
like I'd finished that day or some,
I'd call that person, I'd say,
hey, that thing pissed me off, you know,
like, let's talk about this.
And with the absence of more stimuli all the time,
more planning, my life became very simple, you know,
whereas before I was doing a tour and I have this
and work on that opportunity and it was like,
now you just get up and walk.
Life became very simple.
And that gave me the space to
have everything clear from the past
so I could just be present, you know.
And I think that's really the point, you know.
I forget and after Everest,
like I went on a retreat and was reminded of this,
but we're supposed to like be, we're supposed to be here.
We're supposed to be present.
We're supposed to have enthusiasm
and love and joy inside us.
We're not supposed to spend our lives planning
about the future always.
Sure, you need to do that somewhat,
but we're not supposed to spend our time
dwelling on the past.
We're supposed to be like in our bodies,
like our mind should be in the same place as our body.
And creating some space to just stop, you know.
It was good.
Have a hard time with that though.
We're not wired to be able to hold on to that.
And the half-life of those types of experiences,
whether it's the Loony Tunes circles closing in,
or the mindfulness and the presence
that you were able to experience
throughout that extended period of solitude,
tend to wane pretty quickly
in the wake of those experiences.
So how has that been?
Like, have you been able to carry that awareness
into your life, in the aftermath of these experiences?
That's the, yeah.
Or do you find yourself defaulting back?
Now you're back in LA, you're back in the studio.
Like how much of that are you able to hold on to?
That's a great question.
And sort of become the theme of my life,
at least right now, this version of Mike Posner.
Because I kept getting these Satori flashes of everything,
you know, like in the ambulance,
it was peace and everything made sense.
The summit of Everest, we can talk about that,
but another one of these deeply just perfect moments
where I'm fully present.
But you're right, they disappear, go away.
And it's like, there's gotta be a better way
to access that peace than to fricking almost die
or to risk my life climbing this insane mountain, right.
Like that-
To have to go back to the monastery.
That's the next one.
And so I actually went back to the monastery after Everest.
Actually it's a Buddhist center, there's no monks there.
And they, the place I went,
they have these solo cabins
that are set up for solitary retreats,
which I really liked.
So you go and you drop, you got this little cabin
with a single mattress and they go, see you in three weeks.
And you're just on your own.
Each week, they drop off a week's worth of groceries,
but you don't see the person.
It's like in a drop box.
You just don't, you're by yourself for three weeks.
And I started to realize like, basically,
if you can quiet the mind, right,
that sort of feeling of peace is just there naturally.
And you don't have to like have your dad die
or walk across America or summit Mount Everest
or to be at the monastery.
You just need to have a quiet mind.
And while every moment of my life
is not gonna have the same emotional potency
of finishing the walk or of almost dying and the thing
or being on the summit of Mount Everest, of course not.
Like all of my moments, I believe have the potential
to have an undercurrent of peace in them
and at least awareness, you know, being where I am.
And so I'm back in LA now,
and I'm essentially doing the exact same thing
I was doing before I left on the walk.
I go to the studio.
I work with artists.
I help them write songs.
I sometimes write my own songs.
I produce songs.
But everything's different on the inside.
You know, who I am is different.
And that sort of just like the marquee on the show,
that's like what I'm doing on the outside.
Well, on the inside, my practice,
and I mess it up more than I get it right, Rich, you know,
but my practice is like when I'm in the room
writing with someone and they're speaking,
I'm trying to be present.
That means nothing's in here.
I'm listening to their voice.
Not what the voice in here is saying
about what they're saying and trying.
Maintaining some awareness of the physical sensation
in my body as I'm working.
And yeah, there's some of that peace,
it's here with me, for sure, you know.
And sometimes easier than others.
Being around you, you're a peaceful guy,
like we connect whatever.
It's easier for me to do it with you, than if, whatever.
But that's my practice.
Yeah, I would imagine that's a creative superpower.
You know, the idea that,
it's calm at the bottom of the ocean
and then it's calm at 30,000 feet,
you're above the clouds, right.
And having that clarity or that open space
opens the channel for that creative instinct
or impulse to channel through
like in the moment when you're working on a song.
When I was at the Buddhist center,
I did this like, I would meditate sitting five hours a day
and I'd do like three hours of walking meditation.
Sounds like hard but it's awesome actually.
It's all relative, you walked across America,
so a three hour walk.
No, it's split up like three, one hour.
And like, yeah, it's actually a lot easier
than regular life 'cause nothing's there to upset you.
So if you find yourself upset-
Except your mind is attacking you constantly.
Yeah, well, if you find yourself upset,
you know I'm doing this,
because there's nothing wrong here.
I have everything and no one else is here, you know.
Anyways, the story I wanted-
The mind will search for that thing to hang its hat on.
Exactly.
To pull you out of that moment and distract you.
But like, I'll circle back, but you're right.
It will do that, the mind is clever, cunning.
And in my mind, like the voice,
which I just call it a voice in my head,
I nicknamed it Charlie,
because when in the absence of more stimuli
and other people speaking and all that stuff,
you really start to hear Charlie.
And like, you start to notice Charlie's trends.
We'll, Charlie has some patterns I've noticed.
One is he's frigging way more negative than I thought,
like a lot of doomsday scenarios.
Like, hey, what if I do that?
And then this might happen.
And that might happen and then, oh,
and then like, and then I might die.
And it's like, whoa, how do we get there, you know.
So we got that.
And then the other thing I noticed about Charlie
is he is incredibly repetitive.
Like the same thought over and over and over and over again.
It's like, I got it, man, I got it.
And I had this-
There's Charlie again, looping that thing
that he always talks about so annoying
and boring after a while.
And sometimes it's benign,
but sometimes it's a negative thing.
It's like, dude, like, all right.
There was one day,
I think it was on fifth or sixth day there.
I did my two hours sitting at the beginning of the day
and I was just like, Charlie's getting quieter and quieter.
And then he's just like kind of gone.
And then two hours ends.
I stand up and I realized
that even though I'm not sitting anymore meditating,
I'm still meditating and it's no Charlie.
And I go to make a snack.
I think it was, I had a piece of Wasa bread
and I put an avocado on it.
And while I made it, still, no Charlie.
And I closed my eyes, I took a bite
and it was like fireworks of flavor.
Like I could tell you, Rich,
this without reservation is the best meal
I've ever had in my life.
And the main ingredient is like quiet mind.
And so, I tell you this story to say,
when the mind is quiet, what's left.
It's hard to put into words what's left,
but it's not just like blank.
It's actually like, it's like,
forgive me for this, I can't think of a better way,
it's like taking the condom off life, man.
You're like, this is how avocado really tastes
when I'm not covering it up with all my judgments
and talking in my head and analyzing.
It's like, I remember putting a sock on
on my retreat and feeling like I was having sex,
like putting a sock on my foot.
Like all the senses are heightened
because it just like, we cover them up
with just this blabber box in our head, usually, you know.
And so, it turns out, I think, at least for me,
when we quiet Charlie,
it's not this like state of blankness.
It's like, there's a lot there.
Your brain comes alive.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's wow.
Yeah and that's what I was feeling in the ambulance
when I looked at that red paint and it looked brighter.
That's what I was feeling, you know.
So I think like thinking about reality
is like putting on real dark sunglasses, it dulls reality.
And presence is like taking those sunglasses off.
But I think that practice of naming your thinking mind
allows you to create that distance and that understanding
that there is your mind, which is good at keeping you alive
and doing menial tasks and sort of propelling your body
into forward motion.
But it's really not your friend
when it comes to so many of the important things.
And creating that separation allows you to understand
that there is a gap and a distinction
between your higher consciousness, what it feels like,
the experience of being truly present in your life
and the looping negative thought patterns
of that thinking brain.
That's right.
And that in truth,
you are that higher consciousness.
That's right, you are not that voice.
And this identifying 'cause we all over over identify
with the thinking brain.
That's right.
Right and we think that's who we are.
And developing the capacity to understand
that that is not who we are
and that this is a voice that we can choose
to listen to or dismiss,
I think is a really profound practice.
It's deeper than you can ever imagine, right and-
And fricking hard.
Yeah and continual thing.
And I work on it every day.
But I would say I'm definitely there more
than I ever have been in my life.
And I'm not on the walk across America,
I'm not at the monastery, I'm living a life.
Yeah, you're in the world.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's that adage of it's easy to be serene
when you're in the cave, metaphorically.
Like you're the monk in the monastery or in the cave
removed from the real world.
That's gonna be an easier situation
in which to cultivate stillness and quietude.
But the real advanced degree,
is can you carry that into the world?
That's right.
And practice that when you are immersed in stimuli
and challenges, et cetera.
Yeah, that's right.
And when I was on retreat, I felt that.
It was a lot easier there.
It's set up to just gain a foot hold, you know.
I had a book while I was at the Buddhist center
by Thich Nhat Hanh and there was a line in it.
And it said, retreat is about re-entry.
Retreat is about re-entry.
So what's that mean?
He said that if your retreat
is not making you a better member of society,
a better brother, sister, husband, wife when you go back,
you're wasting your time.
You're not going there to like, feel,
this is what I used to do,
'cause I've been to that place three times.
When I was there I thought I was gonna gain
some super power or something,
or at the very least I was gonna gain an experience
that I could talk about
and tell other people I did this thing.
I thought I was gonna put something on.
Well, that's BS, man.
And
it's selfish.
Like when you go on retreat, you should come back better.
That's what the retreat is for, you know, period.
And when I think about that experience,
when I think about Everest and the walk,
those are all kinda retreats.
And so yeah, what I'm up to now,
is practicing that stuff internally
and then trying to share the stuff I learned.
Because those are pretty cool and privileged experiences.
A lot of people can't take three weeks off of work
and go sit alone in a cabin, or walk across America.
I mean, these are very unique and beautiful experiences
that I was blessed to have.
So yeah, my life now just, I go to the studio
and I try to be present.
And also I just started doing some speaking
and like storytelling where I share some of these stories,
'cause I just want to share some of this stuff I learned.
Yeah.
On the walk, and I promise we're gonna get to Everest.
It's all good.
I know.
One of the things that occurred to me
in thinking about what this was about for you,
and the different Mike that kind of emerged from it
from the Mike that began it,
is this arc of transcending the ego.
Because on some level, yes, the walk is about you,
but deep down, we're all egoistic
and you are promoting an album on some level.
And you're like, oh, if I do this,
this will actually get a bunch of attention.
I'll get a bunch of validation.
And you had this imagined vision of being joined
by like this huge group of people,
as you walked into Los Angeles.
And all of you together would throw this big party
and you'd all go into the ocean.
But what happens is there is this destruction
of the ego along the way,
where you're forced to kind of meet yourself
in a new and different way.
Such that when you arrive in Venice,
it's really about the relationship between you and you.
And you eschewed the temptation
to have a lot of people there
and chose to just have your closest friends
and to walk into the ocean by yourself.
And that's a really beautiful evolution,
I think of Mike Posner.
And perhaps that was something that you had
to contend with again during Everest.
And because we are all naturally egoistic, it flares up.
It's not like you've just transcended it.
And you are this person who has a public facing persona
and has to contend with fame
and everything that kinda comes with that.
But I think that there's something really profound
in that attempt, the striving to mute the ego,
to tap into a greater level of humility and gratitude.
And then just in you describing
how you approach your studio time now,
that strikes me as somebody who's kind of showing up
in service to these artists that you're working with.
Trying to be.
Rather than like, hey, what am I gonna extract
out of this experience.
Yeah, it is a lot different.
Sometimes we won't even write a song.
(Mike chuckles wheezily)
You know, sometimes I can see a person
is just like overwhelmed with their life.
I'm like, let's just go for a walk.
We don't have to write a song today, I don't care.
But yeah, man, you're right.
This ego thing, it's not even real, you know.
Like when I think about who I am, who is Mike Posner,
it's like this loose amalgamation of random memories
that aren't even all the memories, right.
Because I forget most of the stuff that happens to me.
These memories, and then like some cultural archetypes,
like characters for movies that I've like mixed up.
I'm like that's me, that's my personality.
And then you weave a story around that.
You weave a story around it.
Whether it's this trauma happened to me,
and this is why I'm this way.
Right, but this story slash concept slash idea,
I just realized one day, like it only exists in my head.
Like nobody else in the entire world
has that picture of me in their head.
They have, if they even know who I am,
they have a different picture.
And it's much less fleshed out
and they don't care as much about it.
That being said, none of these
story slash concepts slash identities in our heads are real.
Not like this is real, like, this is a real thing.
They're just like these amorphous things
that have no actual tie to reality.
And just remembering, like it always wants you to feel
like you're separate than it, the ego.
Like that's what an ego is.
It's like I am this thing in the world and I'm alone.
And, but in actuality, it's not true, of course.
Like we come from our parents,
we're attached to the planet, of course,
in like deeply inexplicable ways.
Like if the sun was a mile further back,
we'd all be frozen, you know.
Like we are connected to everything.
And just like remembering to make that shift,
life just seems a lot better,
when I'm living from the sort of the big place,
not the ego place.
You can't walk across America, climb Everest
and climb the however many mountains you climbed
in preparation for Everest
and not feel a deeper connection
and sense of interconnectedness with the greater whole.
There is some disillusion of the ego
that would have to take place with that,
because you're meeting nature on such a grand scale.
I think so, I think it can go either way too.
Like, they talk about that with psychedelics too.
It could fuel your ego.
I did all these things, this is who I am.
I'm Mike Posner and on my resume,
I'm the only Grammy nominated guy
who's climbed Everest and walked across America.
And that is who I am.
Yeah, yeah, it could go that way.
So that's like up to you, I guess, you know.
Up to me.
Right.
So you finish this walk.
Along the way, or at some point,
this idea of Everest occurs to you.
Yeah.
It's probably occurred to a lot of people.
But you decide you're actually gonna act on it.
Yeah, it was the snake bite over the Rockies
where I just thought I could do anything.
And that sorta dream, I dreamed about it before,
like I fantasized about it.
And it started to mutate slowly
from a dream into a plan and-
I just remember, it wasn't that long after the walk
where suddenly on Instagram,
it's like you and Colin were,
were you at Mount Hood or something like that.
You guys went on a climb.
Yeah, just two weeks later.
Two weeks later, 'cause I was already talking to Collin
while I was on the walk.
I said, man, is Everest as crowded as they say,
is it like, 'cause you know,
there's a lot of hoopla about Everest,
and misinformation and he'd been there.
Is it crowded, is it really, is it like, is it worth it?
Like, is it beautiful?
He was like, you know what that feeling you get
when you go to the Grand Canyon.
I said, yeah, he's like, it's like that times 100.
I'm like, that sounds pretty good, you know.
And so, he had done a lot of big projects, Colin,
so he kinda gave me some advice, like how to end the walk.
And then he said, look, do you know anything about climbing?
I said, nope.
You ever worn crampons?
Nope, he goes, well, why don't you come climb Mount Hood
with me after your walk.
I said, great.
I go, but look like, I'm really gonna come, you know,
like, 'cause we never met, I'm like,
no, I'm really gonna come.
He's like, okay.
And so yeah, two weeks after walk,
like I was still, still pretty darn sore,
but he took me up Mount Hood and we summited it.
And I asked him, you know,
if I wanna keep getting better at this, how do I do that.
And he goes, you should talk to Dr. Jon.
And he introduced me to Dr. Jon Kedrowski
and that's the man that became my coach
and my guide over the next year and a half.
And I just, I'm all in.
So I moved like basically next to Jon,
I got a rental house there.
In like Colorado?
In Colorado.
And we just fricking trained our butts off
the next year and a half.
What did that training look like?
Jon has a great line,
he says, train for climbing mountains by climbing mountains.
So that's what we did.
When we got to Everest, you sit in base camp a lot,
like waiting for the right weather and your body.
And you start to like forget you're a climber
because you're just sitting there waiting for so long.
And like my whole, the last year and a half
I've been climbing like every few days, like, you know and.
Just hitting all the fourteeners?
Fourteeners, we went to Ecuador,
climbed the volcanoes there.
We went to Pakistan, we went to-
For Pakistan, it was K2?
Yeah, that's a whole other thing.
I just went to base camp.
And you were there when the Nepalese crew
summited in the winter, right?
I was, I had left a few days before,
but yeah, I was at that base,
I just went to base camp.
So you went up to base camp, right.
That's it, I don't really wanna climb K2, man.
I always tell people that-
Well, not in the winter at least.
I don't wanna climb it in the summer either.
I always tell people that when I was doing Everest,
I'm like, look, believe it or not.
I do have a line, you know.
'Cause everyone's line of acceptable risk,
their risk tolerance is different.
And it's fine like you climb within that risk.
And K2 is on the other side of my line, man.
Forget that one.
But yeah, we climb.
And this was like full-time?
You're living in Colorado-
Full-time.
You're there for the sole purpose of-
Full-time, Jon had control of my schedule.
Right.
So, you know, somebody calls,
hey, Mike, can you come, do you wanna do this thing.
I go, I gotta ask my coach.
I had to ask, you know, I didn't have to,
I wanted it to be like that, you know.
And he had control of my schedule first, right.
So he'd say like, we're gonna do
this, this, this and this.
And then I'd put the rest of my life
in between the mountain.
Like, 'cause I told them, I go,
look, I have no interest in going to Mount Everest,
if I don't belong there, period.
I won't be one of these yucko putz
that show up and they never, like.
There's a lot of those.
There's like, I don't wanna do that.
It doesn't interest me.
I wanna go on this journey with you
and become a mountaineer.
And if you think I'm ready, we go together.
He said, great, we'll get you ready and he did.
So anyways, we were at base camp a year and a half later.
And like I said, you're just sitting there
waiting for like a month for the right weather.
And I started to forget that I'm a mountaineer now,
that I'm a climber.
And so I took a notebook out and I had my phone,
all the pictures of stuff from the summits we'd done.
And I just made a list of all the mountains
we'd climbed just to give me, instill some confidence-
in myself.
Remind yourself that
you actually did prepare.
Yeah, now this list, I couldn't believe it,
kept going, it was 71 mountains long, 71 we climbed.
Mount Everest was the 72nd we did together.
Yeah, that's wild.
So in the preparation, what did you like,
'cause I have no experience
with high-altitude climbing of any kind.
I have an idea of what I think
goes into tackling something like that.
And you being a newbie going into it,
what did you discover or learn
that defied what you expected it to be?
Like, you're like, okay, we're gonna prepare for Everest
or this is what it's gonna be like.
And then you're like, oh, I didn't realize it was this.
Yeah, I mean, so many things.
I remember our first mountain, Crystal Peak,
we start climbing and you know on your backpack,
you have the little water bottle holders on the side.
So I have my water bottles in there, right.
I get to the summit, it's like a thirteener.
Ge to the summit, Jon goes, take a drink of water.
Take my water bottle, it's frozen, it's a block of ice.
Can't drink that.
He goes, water doesn't go on the outside of the pack.
Okay, so that's day one.
Just one thing, yeah.
Day one, you know what I mean.
That water is gonna go-
I wouldn't have thought of that.
I didn't think of it, it's gotta go
against your back in the pack.
So it stays liquid, you know.
And then when you go to like, I don't know, you go-
Like probably a million things like that.
There's a million things like that.
But then even so, getting to the big peaks,
because Everest is my first 8,000 meter peak,
to everything's just up a notch.
So even then you put your water in like another thing.
And the thing I really wasn't,
I feel like I couldn't have been prepared for
was just the way that altitude hit me up that high.
I mean, I've been high, I've been 20,000 feet plus,
but this is another 10,000, like 29,000,
you know, 29 on 29.
So and it's exponential, right.
Going from sea level to 1000 is a lot easier
than going from 26,000 to 27.
I mean, light years different.
And I just felt like up there, I just felt like horrible.
I just felt like a zombie.
I couldn't sleep because you know,
we're talking about a third of the oxygen
that you and I are breathing now.
You wake up gasping for air.
As soon, 'cause the respiratory system slows in sleep.
So right when I'd start to (inhales audibly)
just my body thought I was suffocating.
And so, on the summit push,
you're just like no sleep five days.
And you get real, the other thing people don't realize
is yeah, on the summit and stuff, it's really cold,
but you come down that same day
and as you get a little lower on the mountain
and the sun comes out, you're still in that down suit
and you start to cook, man.
Yeah, I know you shared on Instagram,
some posts where you were stripping down
to like the gear you were wearing
when you walked across America.
Yeah, well, that's the-
'Cause you were like
dude, it's getting how.
Things, I wore these.
Yeah, and so, yeah, just like the exhaustion,
the dehydration and the altitude,
I don't wanna say sickness, but yeah, it is, man.
Like you're up there and you're probably at about
just being there, just being there, Rich,
odds about 15%, I would say.
And then you got to climb the mountain with that percentage.
Right, there's only so much acclimation that occurs.
Well, the acclamation makes it so you can do it,
but doesn't make it feel good.
I know that during the training phase for this,
you went out to Poland though and did the Wim Hof.
Yeah!
You're experience with all those guys.
That was awesome.
I was-
You were supposed to be there, weren't you?
I know and I don't know what was going on with me
and I couldn't go, I probably could have, you know,
it's one of those FOMO things,
where I don't know what was going on.
Like that's the point, right.
I can't even remember what it was that I had to do.
Has Wim been on your show?
Yeah, a couple of times.
So have you ever practiced with him?
I have, yeah, I have.
Well, then that's what we did, you're good.
I know, but I wanted to have the Poland experience
and I wanted to go with all you guys.
Yeah.
I was invited and it's like a thing.
And then when you guys were there, I was like,
what am I, why, what, why didn't you do this.
IN-Q said the same thing.
He was invited too, he didn't come.
I know, it looked like a blast.
It was, that practice, I think is life changing, man.
It's really deep.
Right, so the thing is like, did you,
so with those practices, were you able to apply them
at base camp and above to try
to help self-regulate a little bit with
the lack of oxygen?
Yeah, both of them.
I'd say like sort of the two cores
and there's some other stuff, of course.
But like I'd say, the main two pillars
of Wim Hof's method are cold immersion, right,
there's these ice baths, and breath work.
And both of those were helpful for me.
You know, one, is like, look just,
everyone knows, if you live in LA
and you take a plane and you get off
in Detroit in the middle of winter,
it feels a lot colder to you
than it does to someone living in Detroit.
Right?
Right.
So, same process, as I was getting ready to go to Everest,
there was a river by the house
that I was renting in Colorado.
And just get in that thing and in the middle of winter
and just, you know, you take a cold shower,
cold shower in Colorado in the mountains
is a cold shower in the and-
But the thing is, the difference is like,
if you go out and you run every day,
like you're gonna become a better runner
and you can kinda get used to the cold a little bit,
but there's a cap on that.
Like it's always hard.
Yes, but I believe, look, don't quote me on this
'cause I was looking it up before Everest,
I believe there's an acclimation process.
They're saying like they had some guys do ice baths.
And they were, at the beginning they were shivering
after two months or whatever, something,
I think there's some study.
There is that.
Yeah and I've noticed that just through doing it myself,
but it never gets, it's not like, oh, this is easy now.
It gets easier, I would say, for me at least.
Easier, the E-R at the end.
Then you start to really like it, I don't know.
Like for me-
Yeah, that's true.
I still will like stall before I actually get in.
But the high I get from the cold.
Anyways, yeah, man, I would just try to like,
make sure I got cold once or twice every day
before I showed up to Everest
to just change my body's metric of what cold was.
And then the breath work.
Yeah, I did all the time there.
And I really believe in this practice,
so much so that I'm actually studying
to become a instructor.
Oh wow.
I'm doing like the online courses.
Are you?
Yeah, because I just wanna share that practice.
It's so good, you know.
Right.
Yeah, it's beautiful.
And the output of the breath work
is so asymmetric to the input.
It's like the input is breathing, you know, fully,
and then you do some holds and whatever,
you've had Wim Hof on.
And the output is like this amazingly blissful,
peaceful state that like sometimes
is like borderline psychedelic
and you're like, high, like you can do.
I felt like someone gave me a cheat code to my own body.
I was like, how am I 33 and I didn't know, like,
you can just do this whenever you want.
It's really cool.
Yeah, accessible at any time.
With breath.
That will change the experience of your entire day.
Yeah, yeah.
And I'm a meditator, so I meditate twice a day,
every day, pretty much like,
I don't know, eight, nine years now.
And if I ever really get in a funk,
like if I'm just like feeling depressed,
I'll do that breath work and it seems to like-
Shift.
It just seems to be able to pierce through those-
It has much more dramatic,
immediate effect than meditation.
Yeah, I would say so.
Those things are both great,
but they're different qualitatively, I think.
Yeah.
So.
I agree, I agree.
So you're up at base camp.
One of the things that is wild about all of this,
like I didn't realize this
I was looking a little bit more deeply into your story,
is how normal avalanches are that you're hearing them like
all the time when you're at base camp from a great distance.
Yeah, you get there and you hear these thunder
(mimics avalanche rumbling) rumbles and they sound loud.
And you go and you look and these mountains are big, man.
And you're like where,
it sounds like it's coming down on you and you find it.
And it's like so far away and it looks this big,
you know, it's giant, but it's really far away
and the mountains are so big.
So after, we're talking like you probably hear that
five times a day, at least.
And over a period of weeks,
I started to become desensitized to that sound,
it just became kinda background noise.
But Everest it's really dangerous, it's really real.
Basically for every 100 climbers that go above base camp,
one perishes.
In fact, before we saw a weather window
that we liked Jon and I,
four climbers that weren't on our team,
but were in base camp with us, we're dead.
And so, you got guys going up, not coming down.
We had a friend-
That's some heavy shit when you're like I'm next.
Yeah, we had a friend that went up
and came down with really bad frostbite.
And I started thinking like, (sighs) what am I doing here.
Like what,
why am I risking my life here?
And all the bad reasons became really apparent, you know,
like there was some part of me that wanted to be cool
and tough and it's like, well,
that's a pretty dumb thing to die for, right.
And so all these just like reasons,
we were talking about reasons before,
like for me not to do it,
but just one commitment for me to climb
is I said I was gonna do it.
The follow through similar to after the snake bite.
That's right and-
What does it mean to say you're gonna do something
and follow through on that.
Yeah.
But then acknowledging like the ego part of it.
Yeah, I mean-
The validation part.
Yeah, there was a plethora of reasons of why I was there
and a lot of them were cool
and some of them weren't, which by the way,
I think we even talked about this last time,
it was true to walk too.
Like, you know, part of me wanted people,
oh, that guy's cool, you know, whatever.
And like, so, but that,
Everest was so dangerous, so real,
like death so close that that ceased to be,
the looking cool ceased to be something
that was pulling me upward on the mountain,
it became something that was pulling me down.
It was like, hey, man, if that's the reason you're here,
you should turn around, you know.
And it was just, the only thing I had pulling me up
was that commitment, man.
And we saw a window we liked, after, in late May.
And we climbed to camp two, it's about 10 hours.
And it was snowing hard.
It was like a snow storm a couple of days.
So we stayed at camp two.
But we knew there was good weather for the summit
in a few days, but we just had to wait.
And the thing about steep mountains
is it's not good to climb steep faces
the day after it snows.
That's when avalanches happen,
because it's just all this new snowpack
and gravity pulls it down.
So we're just waiting, you know,
after this snow storm a day or two, before we went higher,
because we had to go on the Lhotse face,
which is just, it's real steep.
And we're at camp two, 21,300 feet.
I hate that place, man, it's the worst,
I just feel horrible there, can't sleep.
And you're just there for a couple of days,
you're just in the tent?
You can get out of the tent.
And we had like a dining tent, which disappeared.
I'll get to that like (laughs).
Basically, yeah, I mean, you could walk to the,
there's like a latrine tent whatever,
but it's hard to do anything.
Right.
You know, you walk from where I'm sitting
to you're sitting, I would be breathing like this.
(Mike gasps for air loudly)
Like it's, I mean, I just, I can't explain the altitude.
How hard that makes everything, how bad it made me feel.
And it hits different people differently.
And that was another part of my journey.
I go in the tent one night at camp two with Jon,
Jon and I are in our tent and I'm pretending to sleep.
And I hear one of those rumbles.
I don't think anything of it
because I've heard it so many times by now.
It stops for a second and then all of a sudden,
(blows out air loudly) our tent starts to shake
from all angles, it feels like we're about to be picked up
and blown off the mountain.
A whole rips in our tent.
Snow's hit me in the face, filling up my sleeping bag,
I'm screaming, Jon, Jon, Jon, avalanche, avalanche.
I'm sure in that moment, I'm dead at camp two
the avalanche is hitting our tent.
And then right while I'm screaming,
it just fricking stopped.
And I'm like looking at my hands, they're still shaking.
And I'm like, how am I alive?
What happened?
And we figured out that basically this avalanche slid,
but it stopped just before hitting our camp.
So what we felt was the air blast
of the avalanche's final breaths basically.
But still the damage is real.
Like that dining tent I told you about was gone.
Just from the air?
Just like, yeah, 'cause it's so big-
There's so much air that it
displaces.
It displaces all that air.
Yeah, wow.
Yeah.
And we were lucky, man.
The camp next to ours, Elite Exped's, Nims' camp,
was like destroy and thank God they weren't there.
They were already at camp three.
They had already gone up?
They left the day before.
But they would've been toast.
I mean, something bad would have happened, for sure.
Like, it's like we didn't have time
to feel sorry for ourselves.
And still in this moment, I'm like,
what am I doing, you know.
Shit is is getting real.
What am I doing?
Do I wanna die here?
And still like, there's all these reasons to turn around,
just that commitment to integrity to pull me up.
And so we climb the next day to camp three.
Slept there, next day to camp four.
And then you got a few hours at camp four
to turn it around.
Right, you got like four or five hours
and then you gotta hit it.
Yeah, and it takes two hours to get ready.
Like getting your tank on, your big suit,
all that stuff.
And you're not really sleeping, right,
any of these nights?
No, that's what I'm saying,
I didn't really sleep well, I slept okay at camp three
'cause that's where I put oxygen on.
Camp two, I didn't sleep at all.
Like we were there three days, I felt just bad.
And then, yeah, from you leave three, you go to four,
I got there maybe 11:00 AM and at 6:00 PM,
I'm gonna start getting ready and-
You're hitting the supplemental oxygen
from that point forward?
Once I put it on at three, I never take it off.
So once you put it on, you don't take it off.
Sleeping with it, it's on all the time.
If you somehow take it off or run out,
that's worse than having never put it on.
That's really bad.
Because you've re-acclimated to-
Correct.
When you're doing supplemental oxygen,
is that like sea level oxygen density?
I don't know it's still really hard to like,
I'm still really out of breath, I think it's just-
So even with it, you're still struggling.
Oh yeah.
It's not like, oh,
now I feel totally normal.
No, no, not by any stretch of the imagination,
but it did help me get some, some Zs at camp three.
But yeah, moving real slow up there
and depends how much you have
and how many liters per minute you have it set to also.
Right, you open it up all the way,
but then you're gonna run out.
That's the thing, how many bottles do you have.
So, and that's, you gotta be responsible
for knowing how fast you're going as well
and that kind of thing.
So yeah, at camp four, we had that window
from 11:00 AM to 6:00 PM to rest.
I remember, this is sort of a strange story
I don't tell that much,
'cause I don't really know how to tell it that well.
But I like went into some strange trance,
almost felt like I had psychedelic.
I was having these visions there.
Granted I know the altitude had something to do with it
'cause we were just under 26, like 25,900.
And for about an hour, I was laying in the tent,
my eyes closed and just seeing visuals.
And it almost, yeah, it felt like peaceful in some way.
I felt a little bit removed from the experience
like you're always doing something
like managing something on the mountain.
And I remember that experience kind of felt
like it was giving me a zoom out.
And then it was time to go.
And started getting ready at six.
about 8:30 PM, it's dark
and the wind was blowing pretty good.
But we thought that once we got out of that saddle,
it would be better.
And I'm climbing in a team of four.
Dr. Jon, who we talked about, myself
and then our two local guides,
Dawa Chirring Sherpa and Dawa Dorje Sherpa.
And those guys are like those, my buddies, man.
I still talk to 'em like a lot.
And we start going.
And you're so worried about being,
I was so worried about being cold.
You hear all the stories, frostbite and stuff
that we're going up kinda that first face
and I was like sweating and you don't wanna sweat
on big mountains like that 'cause the sweat freezes.
Freezes, yeah.
And so.
And it's dark out?
It's dark, yeah, it's 8:30 PM when we start.
So we're climbing through the night
and our aim is to be on the summit around sunrise.
I started sweating and I'm like, man,
I gotta stop, take some layers off.
So I stop take a layer.
All these climber start passing me.
And that's the other thing you don't wanna
be in a traffic jam up there.
So after a few hours, there's a natural resting point
called the balcony where everyone takes a break
'cause it's just kind of flat like a balcony
and it has this crazy view.
And I said to Jon, I said, look, when we get to the balcony,
let's take like, everyone else is gonna
take a 10 minute break,
let's take a three minute break
and let's pass everybody.
He said, great.
So I get there and we take this three minute break
and we pass it everybody, except there's only four people
in front of us now.
And I don't usually eat caffeine,
but your appetite also disappears up there.
So I was just eating like, you know, the gels.
Right.
The caffeine, the Cliff shots.
And I was just like, I felt like I had-
Another gear.
Some pep in my step, unlike the days before.
And Dawa Chirring and I,
we ended up passing that group of four
and then there was like these two headlamps way above us.
So we kept climbing,
and we got up there on the south summit
and they had stopped.
It was our friend Erickson.
He was like, hey, man, I think I was going too fast.
I didn't wanna get there in the dark.
So he was just sitting there waiting.
And then Jon came up, he was like, nah, let's go now.
He's like, we're gonna hit it perfectly.
So we walked past Erickson and Erickson came behind us
and Dawa Chirring was in front of myself.
And I just remember like, he went and he went on the summit,
he turned around and he looked me in the eye.
And this is like this moment where you would think
maybe you'd feel some pride up there.
Like I did it, that kind of thing.
But I'm looking this guy in the eye,
who's carrying my extra oxygen, you know.
And it's like, nah, I'm here because of him,
'cause of Jon and 'cause of Dawa Dorje.
That's the only reason I'm allowed to be here, period.
Like if I had to carry all that stuff,
I don't think I could've done it.
And so instead of this pride,
it's just some cocktail of humility, gratitude and love.
And I basically hugged him.
Jon came up behind us and hugged me.
And I flopped onto the summit, man.
I just, I buried my face in my hands on the ground
and tears just explode on my face.
And I remember I said these word,
I said like, they like dribbled out.
I could almost hear it, I was like, this took everything,
This took everything.
And it was just such a beautiful moment, man.
Because Jon and I had been working so hard for it
to be up there with them.
We were both just weeping.
And just like in the back of the ambulance, you know,
it's like there was peace and everything made sense.
How did it differ from the many times
that you had imagined what that would be like?
Like what did you suspect it would look like
and feel like versus the reality?
That feeling of possibility that I had after the walk,
that wasn't there, that wasn't there.
In other words, that idea like,
after the walk, like, oh, I can, there's way more in me.
It wasn't-
But on Everest like, oh, I did everything I could,
but I'm only here because of these guys,
like that level of humility.
That and just like, I didn't wanna do
anything harder than that, I still don't.
Maybe I shouldn't say harder.
I don't wanna do anything more dangerous than that.
In fact, I wouldn't do that again.
You know, I wouldn't, my risk tolerance has changed.
But the moment itself was (blows out air)
it's one of the best moments in my life.
You know, it was everything and more,
it was just beauty, it was perfect, it's beautiful.
People don't realize mountains have shadows.
But if you get to a summit on sunrise, you see the shadow.
I mean, seeing Mount Everest, giant pyramidal shadow
cast over hundreds and hundreds of miles,
it's like, come on.
It was so clear, I mean, I saw the photos.
Well, clear, like, here's the thing.
You're so high up.
You got to realize you're so high,
you're above the clouds.
So, I mean, that's-
It's always gonna be clear up there.
Yeah, there's, it's not always clear.
It can be bad up there.
But on some of the weather reports,
like you'll have like that snow storm we had, right,
where we were waiting in camp two.
Well, that storm was, that 7,000 meters and below.
Like, that's where those clouds were.
So once we passed 7,000 meters,
like there was no new snowfall there.
We didn't have to worry.
You know, it's just interesting,
like you go above the weather to me.
So the moment was, I don't know what I expected,
but it was perfect, it was unreal, man.
It was everything.
The way that journey itself affected my life
was totally different than the walk.
You know, where the walk almost
like we talked about was momentum to do Everest.
Everest was momentum to be here, to be present.
I think that's a really beautiful
and mature takeaway from the experience,
because it's very easy to just let that turn you
into an adventure junkie,
where you've gotten some spike out of that experience.
And you then, you know, basically devote a ridiculous amount
of energy towards just trying to repeat that
or feel something again, like, you know.
And a lot of these guys suck, man.
And you're kind of like missing the point
because you're ultimately running away.
Correct.
Or you're escaping your reality.
Yeah.
Versus like really leveraging that experience
to go deeper into what you just said,
which is like how to be more present
and how to have more gratitude
and humility and all of these things.
I think we might've talked about it last time.
Did we talk about when I met Ram Dass?
I don't know, I don't remember.
Maybe, at the risk of repeating-
If I don't remember, other people don't.
Yeah, that's fine.
So I'm met Ram Dass, I don't know,
eight years ago before I got into all these shenanigans.
And I'll make this a quick story.
But basically I got invited to spend some time with him
at his house on Maui while he was still alive.
And I had read some of his stuff,
listened to some of his talks
and he had had a stroke by then
and so he was in the wheelchair.
And he basically said a bunch of stuff
I heard him say before, right.
But there was something like,
he just loved me and my friends that I was there with.
He didn't know us, but he was exuding this,
like, I don't know, like deep love for us
that it was like a body high or something.
I mean, I walked out of his house.
I keeled over and I was crying.
I felt so connected to like the rusty gate
and like the dirt and the cow shit.
Like he did something just by being him.
And so I thought I wanna do, like,
I didn't feel like I was in the presence of God
or anything like that, I just felt like,
hey, he's somebody who's done his work on himself.
And I thought, I wanna do that, you know.
I want when people are around me, then they'll feel that.
And I honestly, when I stop,
I can't really think anything
more important to do than that.
And when I'm hearing you talk about these adventure junkies,
like a lot of those times, those guys suck, man.
You're like with them and like,
they don't feel like how it feels
to be in the room with you,
where I feel comfortable and its just good.
Like you have a peaceful energy.
And like that's like more-
It comes from decades of, you know,
doing some work and struggling and all of that stuff.
I mean, I think on some level,
the person who is that adventure junkie
is seeking in their own way
and they're out of surface level of self discovery.
And hopefully, like I see the best in people
and that will lead them to other things-
Yeah, you're right, that's a better
way of saying it.
That will deepen
their trajectory.
You're right.
But I think if you get, it's like anything,
if you get stuck, then you're,
if you get stuck in a certain realm,
like you're short-cutting your growth, right.
Like you always have to like transcend
whatever experience you have.
Like take what you can learn from it
and then try to iterate on it or go to the next level.
I mean, there's a saying in AA,
you can't transmit something you haven't got, right.
So when you're telling the story of Ram Dass,
it's like that guy's gone so deep for so long,
and he's carrying such a heavy vibration of love
and wisdom and experience, that yes,
there is something really true and beautiful
and magical about being in the presence
of somebody who has gone that deep.
And you can definitely feel it, right.
And it's very infectious.
And like when you have that experience, you're like,
I wanna be able to, look,
there's a lot of charlatans out there,
there's a lot of people who can go,
anybody can go and repeat whatever Ram Dass has said
or their version of that.
But when you're with them, you can tell.
Like, if you're tapped in even just a little bit,
you can tell the difference, right,
between the hack and like the guy
who's like speaking truth-
That's right.
From a place of deep understanding.
And so, yeah, for me,
it's like, how can I go to that place
so that I can transmit a vibration
that comes from experience, not something I read in a book.
Yeah, that's right.
Have you ever had these experiences,
like the opposite of the charlatan experience
where the charlatan is like this person dressed up
and they're like supposed to be like that guy,
and they're not?
Where I've had these experiences
where people who are not supposed to be that guy
or girl, or they, are.
Sure.
So for example like-
It's simple. It's like politicians.
It's like who wants that job.
There's an inappropriate incentive
that's attracting the wrong people to that role.
So anybody who wants to be the guru,
ultimately can't really be the guru.
Yeah, but I've had these experiences
where people who don't wanna be the guru
have guru qualities, such as like I've been in the studio
with rappers in clouds of marijuana smoke,
draped in 40 gold chains.
And like, I look into our eyes
and they're like, they're there.
And I'm getting like that kind of feeling from them.
And it's like, wow, okay.
It comes in all forms.
I'm pretty sure
you never meditated.
Yeah.
But well, you got it.
I can just tell you're present.
Like, when I'm speaking with you, you right here with me,
you're not somewhere off in the future or in the past.
Like I can feel it, you know,
I always think that's cool too
when that happens unexpected ones.
You were at base camp for a long time, man.
And I think, I didn't really appreciate
just what a huge extended endeavor
the whole Everest thing is.
Yeah.
Like you're out for months?
It was two months door to door.
Is that longer than normal?
'Cause it seemed, like you were sharing on Instagram.
You're like playing concerts
in some kind of coffee house or something.
I'm like, where is he?
It is like-
You're just hanging out for what seemed like forever.
We were, you know.
So below base camp there are these villages, you know,
'cause you hike a week to get to base camp.
And along the way, there's these villages
in the Khumbu Valley of where the Sherpa people live.
And if you get bored, you can go down to one of the villages
and be in a little lower altitude for a day.
Anyways, there was a hurricane I think,
or typhoon or something in the Indian Ocean.
And that was causing the jet stream
to stay on Everest longer than usual.
Now the jet stream hits Everest summit
usually 50 weeks out of the year.
So that's pretty much unclimbable,
at least from my risk tolerance, you know.
And we're talking hundreds of mile an hour winds.
You don't wanna be up there.
And usually in late May when the seasons switches
from spring to the monsoon season,
there's these two weeks where the jet stream
gets pushed off the mountain.
And this hurricane just messed it up
and it was just staying on there longer than usual.
So we had an extremely late summit June 1st.
So yeah, we were there a little longer than we thought.
And you know, that creates some other problems
like lower on the mountain because it's hot,
it starts getting hotter and the anchors and screws
can start to get a little loose and fall out.
And the hotter it is, the more stuff falls.
So I mean, after that close call in camp two,
that sound wasn't background noise anymore to me.
Right.
And so we just kept hearing them.
And after we summited we get down to camp two
really compressing it.
Well, that's a trip like the false finish.
Wanna talk about false finish line,
you summit, but you're only a camp two.
You got to go down through the ice fall which is-
It's like eight hours up,
but then 12 hours down or something like that?
Yeah, it's about a 17 hour day.
So 'cause we started that day at four,
summited came down and two.
But you go to bed and you summited Everest,
but you're not done, you're still fricking on Everest.
And actually the most dangerous part of the mountain
statistically is the lowest part, the Khumbu Icefall.
That's where all the crevasses are and the ladders
and that kind of thing, you still gotta do that.
I didn't realize those were so low.
That's the first thing you do on the south side.
If you climb from the north from Tibet.
Those look terrifying, I've seen all the videos.
Yes.
It's like I want
no part of that.
It's ridiculous.
We had practiced the heck out of that too
on ladders and stuff, so I was pretty countable.
But it's just interesting,
like you practice on all these ladders in America
and you get there and you're wearing crampons.
You get there and like the steps are all smaller.
So its like it doesn't fit the same way anyway.
And Colin and Jenna were up there too right?
Yeah, they went on the
same day as us.
So I thought maybe
you went, you all went together,
but they went up on a different day.
No, same day.
Oh, they did
Yeah, same day.
Just later in the day.
They left a few hours after us, I think.
But once you get to camp for we just lost contact with them,
I mean, the wind is howling.
We didn't know what tent what persons in.
But we summited and then when I was coming down,
I saw him coming up.
And I saw Colin and Jenna and they were pretty much there.
I knew they were gonna make it.
It's pretty cool to see them.
That's like a cool moment because you're like-
He has thing.
That's the guy I was talking to on the walk across America
and like actually here we are right now.
Well, he will helped me so much,
gave me so much advice.
But he does this joke with me because like,
I'm this musician, right.
You know, I'm out like in these crazy places with Jon.
And so anytime like I'm in a place that I guess,
like I on paper, shouldn't be like,
I land in the Skardu Airport in Pakistan.
He always comes up and he's like, he goes,
oh shit, is that Mike Posner in the Skardu Airport.
I'm like, what's up, man.
Then like he's always doing these, like in the grand,
oh shit, is that Mike Posner
on the summit of the Grand Teton in Wyoming,
you know, he's got these like foldered.
And then he did the one.
And actually it was just like, really cool.
Like in that moment where we crossed,
we're on the Hillary Step.
Holy shit.
I don't know,
he didn't have his phone, I think he had
the GoPro or something.
He's like, oh shit, is that Mike Pose
on the Hillary Step of Mount Everest.
I'm like, yeah.
You should do an edit all of those together.
We should, man, we should.
Wow, man.
So here you are in the wake of all of these experiences.
Like, how do you, like, what's the, like,
how do you make sense of all of it?
What is the wisdom that you then carry into the studio?
Like, how does this,
I'm interested in how this all congeals with
and works with the art and your expression.
That's the easy part.
I mean, that just happens.
Quincy Jones said the deeper the human you are,
the deeper the musician you are.
It's true.
So my perspective is totally different, you know.
So where I write from is different.
I don't have to try to do that, you know,
the inspiration just comes up and
it'll just be different and it'll be evolved.
Right, but it gives you something to say.
I mean, you can't be an artist
if you're not living your life.
So if you just sat
in a studio-
That's right.
In Hollywood for the last four years,
you could create technically good music,
but it would be devoid of the depth
that you can give it now that you've lived
like these rich experiences.
Yes and there's a balance, right.
Because there's skills involved in what I do
that I wasn't focusing on.
And in some way, some of those things
probably waned a little bit.
My guitar chops are not as, you know.
But you're right, I've had periods of my life
where it was the opposite,
where I was just writing a song every day.
And after a year of that, I'm writing some song about,
I don't know, in my early 20s I'm writing some songs
about like being at a party.
And I'm realizing like,
when's the last time you've been to a party, man,
you don't do that, you just write, that's all you do.
And I always talk about this experience I had
with "Redemption Song", Bob Marley.
That's my favorite song.
I'm listening to it one day and I'm thinking,
I know all the chords in this song, I can hit all the notes
and all the words in the lyrics are in my vocabulary.
So why haven't I written a song this good?
Well, that delta between wherever I am
and wherever "Redemption Song" is,
is not found in the studio.
It's not found by practicing guitar, you know,
making my voice better in voice lessons
or learning new words by reading.
It's something deeper than that.
And I think that's part of the quest I've been on.
Yeah, you gotta have a deep reservoir of life experience
to get to a place where you have something to say
worthy of a song like that
and worthy of you being a steward of that expression.
And when the universe decides that you're ready,
I have no doubt that it'll just flow out of you-
Thank you.
Without thinking without, what's it, Charlie.
Charlie.
Without Charlie getting involved.
Charlie's not gonna have any part in that one.
(both chuckling lightly)
But you came out of the gate
with this freaking catchy tune, "Mama Always Told Me."
Yes.
I can't get that
out of my head.
Hey, hey.
I don't know what it is,
but you have a knack for like writing these songs
that just get lodged in the brain like that-
Thank you.
That like pop sensibility, you know.
I don't know where I got that.
Do you think about that or is it just,
I'm just doing what I feel?
Or do you think, I know that these
are characteristics of a pop song that work
and so I structure my lyrics or my beats around that?
Like how does it come together?
You try not to think about that too much, you know.
But there is a frame, like there is a medium.
We call it a medium of the song.
What, it's about three minutes,
it's shrinking as our intention spans shrink,
songs are actually becoming shorter.
And there's like a typical structure to the medium,
which is, there's a verse, a pre-chorus,
a chorus, another verse, another pre-chorus, another chorus,
maybe a post-chorus, a bridge, one more chorus.
And that's the end of the song.
And so we play with this form,
I play with this form.
Right, in the way
a painter plays with a canvas that's mounted on a frame.
And sometimes we say, hey, we're not gonna do it.
Maybe this song is just gonna have one verse
or, you know, whatever.
We're not going to use that.
And but the medium exists, you know, before me.
And so I'm toying with it.
And it's all about what you're trying to accomplish.
And, you know, I guess what the Spirit is calling you to do.
Sometimes you'd think of a melody that's extremely catchy,
but it's like almost so catchy, it's kinda corny.
And then you're kinda, I don't, that doesn't fit, you know.
So it's just, it's always different.
Yeah.
The music industry to seems
to be always changing so quickly.
I mean, it's changed so much just since
the last time that we talked.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Now it's about TikTok and having your songs trend there.
And I know you've had some success with that.
But the idea of like, I'm gonna release an album
versus I'm going to drip songs out.
How do you even approach it strategically to think,
you know, thinking about like, this is how you do it now,
or this is the way the music kind of environment functions
versus the days when we were growing up where it was,
you put an album out every couple of years and tour on it?
Yeah, yeah, that's certainly changed.
For me, I'm just trying to create
or live the life I wanna live.
I don't want to, right now at least,
go on like a big music tour.
I'm really interested in speaking.
And I just did my first speaking thing,
I went to Ohio State like a-
Oh, that's cool.
45 minute talk where I shared some of these stories
and had like some slides.
And then I played a few songs acoustic at the end.
That was awesome 'cause-
You could do a full one man show that way.
Yeah, retreat's about re-entry, you know.
That's what it's called?
No, but that's why I'm doing it.
You know, it's like, okay,
you got to do all this cool stuff.
What'd you learn and can you share with other people
in a way that adds value to them?
So man, like I'm probably the wrong person to ask
about like how we market music now.
I don't really know.
You're just trying to hold on to the purity
of what you do and let that stuff take care of itself.
Yeah.
But you're doing like a combination
of writing for yourself and then working with others.
Yeah, because I really enjoy that, you know.
And sometimes the writing is just an excuse
to share some of this stuff, with younger artists.
I didn't have anybody telling me
what to expect or what to do 10 years ago.
It's a wild, lonely industry, you know,
especially when you have success.
So that, and then as far as like how I'm sharing this stuff,
like I'm playing around on TikTok.
I'm just being real on there.
Like showing what I do.
I sprout, you know, I make music
and that's about it, dude, you know.
(Mike laughs lightly)
And no big, crazy adventure on the horizon?
Not right now.
Like do you feel like
people are like, well, what's next?
What are you gonna do?
They do ask me that.
That's the, there's no next, right.
It's like, that's what I learned.
There's no next, there's only here, it's only now.
Like to anyone listening to this,
like news flash, this is your life.
This is it, whether you're like,
got the earphones in while you're making food or whatever,
like look around like, this is it, you know.
And who said it, maybe it's Thich Nhat Hanh,
and he said, if we can't be happy now,
we can never be happy.
I think he quoted the Buddha
saying that we have to make this moment
the most wonderful moment of our lives.
So that's like my snarky answer.
And then like on the external plane, I'm up to stuff.
I'm doing the speaking.
I'm making music mostly with others now.
But I'll make another album for sure at some point.
Yeah.
And as far as the adventure stuff,
I'm taking a break, you know, that,
Everest was really real, man.
It was, just so easily,
you could've not come back, you know.
And so I still love being in shape,
exercise and that, like that's a part of my life.
But putting my life on the line
and if you die, like who does it really hurt.
Not you, you're fricking dead.
It's like my mom, you know,
like that's not really, you know.
And there's certain things I would like to think
I would die for if like she was in harm's way or, you know.
But just to like have a cool experience
to like access a peace
that I think can be accessed in other ways,
I wouldn't risk my life for that anymore.
Yeah.
And-
I think that's smart, that's a good move.
Yeah, so it's cool.
I feel really good, man, I feel really good.
Dr. Jon and I are also, we're talking about this idea,
maybe next fall of, you know,
speaking of retreat is re-entry and sharing,
we're thinking about hosting like a small group,
maybe 15, 16 people on the trek to base camp.
'Cause that's actually like kind of one of the coolest parts
to Everest is just being in the Sherpa villages
and there's no cars and we're thinking
about like hosting a trip there,
but we're figuring that out still.
Yeah, that's really cool.
Yeah.
And didn't you, weren't you working on a song
with Tom Morello and like laying down lyrics on your iPhone,
like you were at base camp?
No, so, well, first of all,
I got to work with Tom Morello, man.
I know that's like the coolest.
I'm a big Rage fan since I was little.
So we had this song done and it was an idea I had,
I sent to him and then he did his thing with it.
And basically, you know, I produced the song,
which like essentially means
I should be overseeing the mixing process
and like taking the song from,
this is one of the hats I wear, producer.
Like you like finish it,
you know.
Right.
But I didn't, I just like left to Nepal
and Tom's texting me like,
yo, have you heard the latest mix.
It's like, when you nitpick stuff,
hey, the reverb's too loud in verse two or whatever.
And I'm just like, dude, I can't,
'cause there's some crappy WiFi at base camp.
I said, look, man, I see you sent it,
but I can't open it up I'm at Everest base camp.
And I came back and he is like I said, FaceTime,
I was like, yo, I wanna apologize,
I really like, kinda dropped the ball on finishing the mix.
And he was like, oh, he's like, it's all good.
And he's like, so you trekked to base camp.
Because that's a thing,
like that's kind of a life-changing trip people do.
They do the trek to base camp.
And that's what me and Jon are talking
about hosting in the future.
I said, no, I summited.
He was like, what, you summited.
I was like, yeah, man.
He's like, oh shit, he's like, it's all good, man.
We'll finfish the mix, you know.
Right.
So yeah, we got it done
when I got back.
Yeah, it's a pretty
legit excuse like, couldn't get back to you.
Sorry.
I was at camp four.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow.
But that song hasn't come out yet, has it?
It came out, I wanna say-
Oh, it did.
It's Tom song.
Tom made an album, that's not a Rage album
where he collaborate with all these different artists.
And got like, Springsteen's on it and Chris Stapleton.
All these names that I don't deserve to be on the CD with,
you know.
Sure do, man.
No, it was just really cool.
And I think he put it out a week or two ago.
Yeah.
I'll have to check it out.
I didn't know it was out.
Yeah.
Well, dude, I love you.
I'm such a fan, not just of your music,
but just you as a human being.
And I really enjoy being in your presence.
And I think the way, the choices that you've made
about how to live your life, how to conduct yourself,
how to be a public figure with integrity
and live your life in such an authentic way
is truly inspiring, man.
And I'd like to have more of you in my life.
So I really appreciate you coming here today.
Hey, listen, man, that means a lot.
And what you're up to, it's so beautiful.
Like you have some of the most like beautiful people
in the world on your show and you share their message.
And people hear it, I met 'em.
I would say that's probably like of all the interviews I did
on like the, I was telling you before, I think,
we start recording on the walk, you know,
like people showed up so many times
in all these different states
that said they heard your podcast.
And beyond like just highlighting your guests,
whatever they're up to, you take the time
and create a space where you really see them.
And that's a gift.
Like when you, just by some of the things
you reflect back, I can hear in your listening,
like you get me on a level deeper than most,
than you get from just having a conversation with somebody.
Oh, I appreciate that.
So that's a real gift,
you know, to share with other people,
to your listeners, but also each person, I think,
that sits in this chair gets that from you, I presume.
So thank you, man.
Thanks, man.
I appreciate that.
Speaking of gifts, are you willing to share a song with us?
I don't have a guitar guitar, they said you had-
We have a guitar here, it's not your guitar.
I wanna to test it out.
I don't know, we'll see.
Yeah, let's do it.
If it meets your standards, then we can do it.
Let's do it, man.
All right, cool.
Of course.
(mellow guitar music)
♪ Old pirates, yes, they rob I ♪
♪ Sold I to the merchant ships ♪
♪ Minutes after they took I ♪
♪ From the bottomless pit ♪
♪ But my hand was made strong ♪
♪ By the hand of the Almighty ♪
♪ We flower in this generation ♪
♪ Triumphantly ♪
♪ So won't you help to sing ♪
♪ These songs of freedom ♪
♪ 'Cause all I ever have ♪
♪ Redemption song ♪
(mellow guitar music)
♪ Emancipate yourself from mental slavery ♪
♪ None but ourselves can free our minds ♪
♪ Have no fear for atomic energy ♪
♪ 'Cause none of them can stop the time ♪
♪ How long will they kill our brothers ♪
♪ While we stand aside and look ♪
♪ Some say it's just a part of it ♪
♪ We've got to fulfill the book ♪
♪ Won't you help to sing ♪
♪ These songs of freedom ♪
♪ 'Cause all I you ever have ♪
♪ Redemption song ♪
(mellow guitar strumming)
(mellow guitar music)